well i think all our hearts are full of
shock and sadness
today uh to the loss of sir david amos
mp who was killed in his constituency
surgery uh in a church after
almost 40 years of continuous service to
the people of essex and the whole of the
united kingdom
and the reason i think people are so
shocked and saddened is above all he was
one of the kindest nicest most gentle
people in
politics
and he also had an outstanding
record of passing laws to help the most
vulnerable whether the people who are
suffering from
endometriosis
passing laws to
end cruelty to animals or doing a huge
amount to reduce
the fuel poverty suffered by people
up and up and down the country
david was a man who
believe passionately in this country
and
in its
future
and we've we've lost today
a fine public servant and a much loved
friend and colleague and our thoughts
are very much today with his wife his
children and his family and what was the
sense of shock when you and your cabinet
colleagues heard about this it's not
news of course that anyone would be
expecting to hear on friday after
constituency
surgery and somebody who of course has
been as you say a conservative mp for a
very long time nearly 40 years um what
was your the reaction of you and your
colleagues when that news filtered
through i think everybody was
deeply shocked and and heart stricken
and our thoughts as i say are very much
with his with his family uh with his
wife with his children and for the rest
i mean we must really leave the the
police to get on with their
investigation thank you very much